aussi sur l'élection présidentielle elle
même je trouve que cette élection
elle est aujourd'hui presque
infantilisante pour les français
pourquoi parce qu'on va choisir une
personnalité un homme en l'occurrence il
ya peu de femmes pas y en a on a une
annonce sondages mais qui est censé
incarner à lui seul toutes les solutions
trouvées
voilà comment sortir le pays de la crise
et des difficultés tracer un avenir
moi je pense que ça c'est justement ce
qui fait que la france est un pays
aujourd'hui en crise je fais un discours
que porte jean luc mélenchon que mais
pour benoît qui néanmoins jean luc
mélenchon mais lui il est joué
ab oui les l'anjou 7/5 il a une
conception très personnelle très très
auto-centrée doit les laisser là l'air
dans sa campagne actuelle elle est du
côté de jean luc mélenchon fait ce que
montrait également le sondage là il a
des scores très très élevé à chaque fois
est ce que vous pensez qu'il est devenu
une figure rassurante comme il le
prétend lui-même est ce qu'il peut
désormais incarner une gauche de
gouvernement
ce que vous lui dénier il a été dans des
gouvernements socialistes donc il a fait
partie de la gauche de gouvernement un
moment donc il n'ya pas de là pas de
raison qu'il ne soit pas moi j'ai jeudi
qu' il prétend changer la manière
d'exercer le pouvoir
il parle beaucoup de démocratie
participative mais sa campagne elle est
totalement centrée sur sa personne et
peut-être et donc permet d'avoir brillé
mais c'est un paradoxe parce que je ne
pense pas que la fin justifie les moyens
et je pense qu'il faut faire une
campagne à l'image du président qu'on
veut être benoît hamon c'est ce qui fait
il a mis en place un conseil citoyen il
incarne par sa manière d'être
cette proximité qu'il souhaite avec les
français avec les citoyens les autres
tous les autres les quatre autres en
l'occurrence là sont tous dans une
démarche de quasiment 2 de culte de la
personnalité c'est moi je moi je moi je
je vais répondre à vos préoccupations
c'est le mythe de l'homme providentiel
et je pense que ça il faudra tourner la
page là dessus et je pense que c'est